[Applause]
well case had the funniest
i told i made him do it on stage but he
was like can you imagine if like
you were like your husband was like an
innocent bystander there and you're like
so shocked about it and then you're like
wait where was he he was doing what yeah
yo there's some people that got a lie
about where they were that yeah
and they were in the thick of it that's
crazy
no some dudes were getting beat off that
day
and the cops got to question them
they're like i'd rather not
well the wife is mourning her husband i
can't believe it and then like this
[ __ ] what
oh you're talking about the family yeah
you're dead imagine that's your dad
like my dad oh my god so i had to run in
i heard him i was going to save him
i tried to stop it oh my lord yeah you
gotta
i was trying to jump in front of the
bullet yeah you gotta you gotta build a
whole hero story
to to cover the fact that you were
getting beat off yeah it's your only
hope
wow but actually i was talking to ben
about this about like how insane about
how he's related
sexlessness makes you so pissed and
angry and stuff yeah but if that's true
you would expect it would be the people
in the culture that are like
most commonly sexless that are not
getting any sex that would be the most
angry
you know what i mean like so like
statistically it's like yeah that's what
we're saying they're shooting up
but it's like asian dudes that like are
like rejected by women at a high rate
because they're not seen as like
sexually desirable
maybe they don't have the extra indian
dudes
but there's never indian terrorism but i
would say that that's a function of the
community that you're within
so if you're a white dude you see all
your friends out here getting [ __ ] you
go on instagram you see these white
dudes cool [ __ ] getting [ __ ] and the
expectations you should be getting all
this [ __ ] and you're not getting
anything then
that resentment comes right but if in
your community
like akash i don't know if you felt like
an outlier within your community
or you were like no this is kind of like
down with the values we're supposed to
uphold
yeah a lot of my most of my friends were
[ __ ] in like college but it wasn't
like
crazy that i wasn't right yeah because
so it's like you're not that abnormal
to my white friends i was a [ __ ]
mutant to my black friends i was like
actually the southern christian ones got
it but outside of that they were like
what the [ __ ] is this thing
that's funny that they low-key looked up
to it a little bit they were like that's
what i'm supposed to be doing yeah
yeah but even the white ones are just
like i'm christian but you're gay
so i guess you need the community to
make you feel comfortable with that
decision yeah but if it's not a decision
like
like if you're just trying to like [ __ ]
white chicks and they're like nah i
don't want that
yeah like i would expect them to be the
most angry like
yeah you would expect it if they if
they're judging themselves completely
outside of the asian community
right you know what i mean and i think
i'm trying to wrap my form this fully
but like the women you're trying to have
sex with
are they openly trying like down to have
sex or not like
indian girls asian girls you don't know
culturally to be down to [ __ ] like be
out there or whatever right but white
girls [ __ ] sorority if you're a white
dude who wants to [ __ ] white girls
you're looking at the white girls and
they're not
like usually super conservative and
pretending they don't [ __ ] anybody so
you're like yo you're having sex with
all these people but not me
indian guy's not looking at indian girls
like you're having sex with all these
dudes and not me
no but why aren't indian dudes trying to
[ __ ] white girls and then going yeah
why aren't they don't want to [ __ ] me i
think that there might be a societal
like you just that's what we perceive is
happening throughout society so i'm not
the freak
they're just not having sex with indian
dudes it's not me that's the freak
indian dudes are just undesirable and
that sucks and i could be frustrated
about that
but it's not about me yeah you have a
cover
that's my that's what i'm thinking
themselves in norway
like you know like it's the happiest
country in the world so why they have
the high suicide rate and then people
are saying well imagine everybody was
happy around you and you're depressed
yeah that's funny like that's got to be
horrible but if everybody's depressed
around you and you're depressed you're
like oh
this is normal yeah right whereas if
you're a white dude keeps on getting
rejected
you're like she's banging other white
dudes he's being another tall guy
i'm supposed to be desirable yeah
everybody who's out here getting dick
[ __ ] except me right right you feel
like just such a loser yeah that
actually makes sense yeah so i think it
has to do a lot with the community
but yeah ben was i was asking him about
the asian the hate thing he said
something interesting he was like
um he goes uh asians
don't he's half asian he's half japanese
and half white
uh abnormal and uh
he said uh he's like here's the thing
with us is like we don't get seen as
fully american
and i'm sure you've probably experienced
this too yeah and like like he his
relatives like his grandfather and
grandmother were in the internment yes
you know so like this is unpleasant from
his lineage but and his dad was born in
america but
three generations were born yeah in
america right so
his grandpa his great grandfather born
in america this [ __ ] is american
he's more american than me 100
you're not any yeah
right like you weren't born here welcome
so uh so so he was saying we don't get
looked at as
american we still get look at other and
then
he said that a lot of this uh he goes
ask yourself he goes does anybody hate
asians and i go dude i don't know
anybody that hates
asians right there he goes he goes i
don't he goes i don't think people hate
asians
i just think people actually don't think
about us because we don't operate
on like the extremes of society like
there's no asian denzel washington
there's no asian you know i'm trying to
think of like a
huge you know ceo or something that we'd
be familiar with yeah some famous
musician or whatever
yo yo ma is the most famous asian
musicians that you may probably think i
don't even know if he plays an
instrument no asian elon
musk no asian michael jordan right
exactly
like he's like if you think of the most
famous asian person that you know go
what do you think of this
jackie chan bruce lee something like
that yeah
yeah that's what yes andrew yang or
something like that and even that is
kind of like
kind of rare right so what what asians
have done is
uh he said something so it's easy kind
of to hate
them or see them as other as a
reflection of like nationalism almost in
a way
like it's easy to go oh you guys are
responsible for the coronavirus or
whatever that is
because even though they're american
they're not seen
as american right by americans like
weirdly when it comes to the racial
component is nobody's comparing
who's gotten worse obviously black
people have gotten worse here than
anybody but
american akash made this point to me a
long time ago he goes america is kind of
black and white like yeah black people
are american and white people are
american and then everybody else
is kind of you just got to like pick a
side like people tell me i don't
you act black you act white okay how do
i act indian in america yeah what do i
do yeah they have no reference
i swear the only thing i knew to do part
of why i was pre-med i was like i think
that's what i'm supposed to do part of
it
al you're shaking your head i just i
just give a little pushback it's like
it's black and white but then there
is a portion of white that say think
it's just white
oh it's supposed to just be well that's
the thing it's supposed to just be white
let me let me clarify that um there is a
black american way to be
and there is a white american way to be
identity wise
there's a black identity in america
whether you want to choose it or not
white identity in america whether you
want to choose
and most of us are a kind of combination
of both
like you and i are both influenced by
like white and black culture
right and you're skewed more black and i
skew more white but we both have these
influences
from these other cultures right you and
i are not influences by
asians or indians at all or at least you
don't think you are at least
at least we don't think we are like you
know maybe maybe i am and maybe akash is
like rubbed off on me in ways but
you if you and i were like talking and
we like did some random indian [ __ ] we'd
be like
bro why did you just do that that's a
good point
indians i think and asians are going to
be influenced by the
white and black cultural impulses that
they're going to because yeah we don't
have an identity here there is no like
newer dude like yeah it'll take time and
it'll happen but right now
yeah there is no identity there and
furthermore to uh's point is
asians haven't assumed the positions of
influence that black and white people
have yeah so white people let's say go
towards like business and politics which
does
influence culture uh black people go
towards
entertainment right which influences
culture you could argue even more
so these things are permeating american
culture globally
whereas asians and you can include
indians in this as well
we're like we're going to go for law
we're going to be lawyers
doctors dentists we're going to be
successful we're going to sacrifice
the crazy dreams the rolling the dice
risking it all
being a [ __ ] basketball player
musician or something like our comedian
right for something that is secure and
safe
i think for our parents the crazy dream
happened yeah
yeah their basketball career their nba
nfl they made it to america but that was
a crazy dream yeah so it's like yeah
just play it safe and then to your point
to add on to it
then you don't get if you're not in
those things it's easy to be like oh
they're not american because i don't see
asians at all until recently like in
movies in basketball
so black people are asking are you
hating black people you hate michael
jordan he said something he
enjoy that he goes he goes in a way we
made a deal with the devil and i go what
are you talking about he goes
no i'm not upset about this this is
great like we make more money than white
people
right right like we have a higher uh
like per
house income than white family right
we're killing it here but
that comes at the cost of feeling part
of the fabric
of society he goes i think that's why a
lot of asians end up being police police
officers i go what do you mean
he goes they just kind of want to feel
like they're part of this thing
and i think that's probably why you see
a lot of black people join the military
maybe why a lot of asians join the
military as well i think there's other
reasons as well but like
when you fight for the country you can't
take away the americanness right
you know what i mean you see a lot of
latinos join the military as well yeah
maybe that's part of like hey i'm in on
this [ __ ] yeah you're not gonna tell me
i'm not american when i got this [ __ ]
outfit on
yeah you know and it was just a really
cool observation like they got all this
success in america
without integrating into like the
cultural influence and
fabric of it yeah and because of that
they're kind of invisible they're
invisible
yeah and because they're invisible it
seems
as if it's easier to for lack of a
better word hate
asians it's just a little bit easier to
they feel more foreign it's different
they feel
foreign yeah yeah and we talked about a
little and this is why he pointed out
like
asian female fetishization like it's way
easier to fetishize asian women
because
[Laughter]
it was like shrimp it took a second you
know
he was saying that tinder released like
data and they said that asian women were
swiped on the most
like above like white women above
anything and so he was like asian women
white men
yeah and so he said the reason is like
they uh
like it there's like that invisibility
and like he called it kind of like
dehumanization
yeah but like it's not in a hateful way
it's just like oh it's difficult to
necessarily associate because i don't
see you represented anywhere yeah so
therefore i could see you as doll like
and
like uh sexual in that way remove you
from your humanity yeah he said
and there's something he's like listen
we went for the bag right he goes
and we have this conversation there's
like so many outside influences in terms
of what you can or can't do and what
you're supposed to do and like cultural
influences but like
he basically was like we tried to secure
the bag and now we got to try to secure
some sort of cultural influence
and he goes and black people secured
cultural influence
now they got to go secure the back right
and it's like they're opposite side of
the spectrum now
this is so complicated is it to chalk it
up to like
black people going we're going to take
over entertainment it was more like
they won't let us do anything yeah yeah
there's laws against this
exactly exactly he recognized that he's
not saying that but in a way
these outside sources that push people
and push these two groups of people in
different directions
they've kind of now you guys kind of
have to flip yeah
in a weird way yeah you know listen
there's many groups that can be upset
about the shooting at the massage parlor
asians obviously feeling targeted their
lives right now
i think black people got to be pissed
off about this
because for years people have been
telling black people
yo uh it's your culture
that's bad why don't you just go be
successful
go to school you know get good jobs
don't commit crime why don't you not
commit crime why don't you don't do all
these bad things you're doing all these
bad things and that's why you keep
ending up in jail
that's why you're getting shot for no
reason because you're doing all these
bad things
and then you look at these asians in the
salon that
start their own business they go to
school they do all the things that
consider these like crazy alt-right
conservative [ __ ] say black
people should do and they get shot up
for no reason yeah
so the point is [ __ ] get shot
up for no reason it's not because
your education rates are lower
what it is is that when you get looked
at in a dehumanized way
it's easier to [ __ ] shoot somebody
yeah one thing i was seeing
there was like uh two groups of
let's just say minorities that were four
protect
asians like let's stop the hate against
asians and then the other group is like
well what about us we get you know we
have
more violence acts happening to us so
it's like
it was like one group is like yo we
should stand for everybody and the other
group is like
nah we're bigger victims so like why are
we paying attention to them when we're
still the biggest victim yeah
and like i saw that but i like the
pushback of the people who were just
like
no no we got to stand with that is
interesting yeah go go go
no just like seeing like certain black
people's response to
like the parlor thing because there's
certain black people like probably the
majority
that i've seen on like twitter and stuff
being like stop asian hate the whole
hashtag whatever
but then there is a subset that like you
were saying like that
aren't on with it because of either like
feeling like the bigger victim or some
other like complex reason i don't know
but it is interesting seeing how
that shifts and especially for white
people to see that and be like
because i think oftentimes white people
will group like racial groups into
just their like monolithic paradigm like
this is what they are like black people
aren't racist they can't be racist
asian people can't be raised as blah
blah and then they see black people
being like
prejudiced towards asian people yeah on
twitter and being like oh well you came
to
new york and ruined it blah blah and
it's interesting for white people being
like oh wait this is not
all one cohesive group that all believes
the same thing and
if for them i don't know it's
interesting to see the shift yeah it's
tricky man
it is also tricky just because of like
the relationship between black people
and asians
and it hasn't been a very friendly one
throughout like the american experiment
at least growing up for me like i saw a
lot of racism towards my black friends
from the asian community
right and i'm not talking about the
asians i went to school with but i'm
talking about like if we were in
chinatown we're going into like
the asian bodegas or whatever like that
it was always a little bit
you know be followed around and [ __ ] we
would steal from them
but you got treated fine yeah that's
that's where it's [ __ ] up
um but uh but yeah but so it is a weird
thing where like i don't know i guess as
black people you guys got to make a
decision like
do you put that aside and ride for them
and then hope that
they also ride for you in the future
you